alors de façon précise je suis candidat
centriste est en fait
notre candidature car je ne suis pas
tout seul en forme à un quatuor elle
l'est elle s'inscrit dans une certaine
logique qui est de faire en sorte que la
gestion du conseil départemental à venir
et bien soit fins de façon raisonnée de
façon pragmatique c'est ça le sens de la
présence du centre dans ces élections
oui je suis chef d'entreprise j'ai 37
ans et je conseil municipal à evry
depuis l'année dernière
en deux trois mots effectivement on a en
priorité je l'évoquais tout à l'heure
une gestion du conseil départemental qui
doit absolument être vue aujourd'hui le
conseil départemental est en
ile-de-france
selon diageo département le plus le plus
imposé le plus endetté
celui qui investit le moins donc c'est
une véritable gestion qui doit changer
c'est la première des choses
naturellement nos concitoyens et c'est
le deuxième point sont également
contraints aujourd'hui en terme d'emploi
ont des problèmes d'emploi
qu'il aimait le quotidien et de ce point
de vue la priorité au développement
économique et à l'emploi est notre
deuxième objectif voilà et puis
naturellement le domaine du conseil
départemental c'est le social et partant
de là on a un certain nombre de mesures
destinées aux stylos à destination par
dont notamment les personnes âgées dont
on veut absolument qu'elle puisse rester
chez elles le plus longtemps possible un
centre de mesures
et donc les personnes âgées il s'agit de
revaloriser les aides financières
médical et les aides financières aux
ménages par exemple pour les personnes
âgées et pour également des personnes en
situation de handicap par exemple auquel
on pense souvent trop peu un certain
nombre de mesures qui ne coûtent pas
forcément de l'argent mais qui sont des
mesures de bon sens en citer une phrase
en bleu fait de différent unique pour
une personne handicapée
lequel référence gérerait tous les
aspects de la vie de sept personnes
handicapées aujourd'hui c'est un manque
une personne handicapée dans les
différentes phases de sa vie dans les
différents aspects de sa vie et bien
doit référer à à plusieurs personnes et
ses sources de d'inefficacité voilà
quelque chose qui pourrait être corrigée
voilà en trois mots
ce que sans nos le conte aimerait porter
au conseil départemental si les lévriers
mezze vriendt et les couronnes et nous
faisait confiance le 22 mars